hopefully it's not too late I honestly I
don't know if like I hopefully I'll find
somebody Drake talks day
darn and marriage rare no
no but turns out it's all part of a deep
fake series to promote his joint album
with 21 Savage
still gonna turn it all the way up on
Wednesday the musician posted this clip
to Instagram it's a very real looking
fake chat with the radio personality and
let's just say he left his filter at
home you said you were open about porn
what type of porn are you watching what
is your thing
top wow holy highest tier of top givers
that's really what I'm actually
consistently like on a daily basis tuned
into like right just really like those
are like the real superstars of the
world to me yeah Drake kicks off the
convo describing his favorite genre
films look I love
for real you don't love me yeah I love
if you love me then you make them other
girls and your phone disappear and when
it comes to his current view on dating
he says he's not exactly a one-woman
kind of guy right now I feel like I get
into this habit of dating like four or
five women to make one woman because I
like like these like two things I like
like what this girl does for a living so
putting a ring on it isn't really top of
mind for Drake but he isn't ruling out
marriage in the future I think that
eventually once all this is said and
done for us and that addiction of work
and success and forward movement is over
I feel like we're all gonna need
something real hopefully it's not too
late I honestly I don't know if like I
hopefully I'll find somebody I gotta
figure out what my brand of love will be
you know the woman that's going to have
my children child children whatever I
gotta figure out who that's gonna be
mans biggest thing is I need to be
inspired so
I just don't ever I don't know where
when like I don't know how to find that
with the like with the porn
question in there with the other like I
just need all those things Drake
captioned the clip quote absolutely no
filter with the incomparable Howard
Stern thanks for having us you know life
is about Evolution so it's about having
a different brand of fun now but that
wild chat is all just promo for his new
album with 21 Savage her loss dropping
Friday in fact that footage from stern
was ripped straight from a Gerard
Carmichael interview you said you were
open about porn what type of porn are
you watching are you watching what is
your thing well I was saying like I
think being closeted probably like
attracted me to like versions of secret
sex you said you were open about porn
what type of porn are you watching what
is your thing
top wow holy highest tier of top givers
well they sure know how to get people
talking yeah I'm excited but Drake and
21 Savage didn't stop there the two also
shared this clip teasing a faux
performance on NPR's tiny desk series my
name is Drake 21 Savage and uh this is
our tiny desk let's get it yeah let's
get into it and they shared this fake
Vogue cover thinking editor-in-chief
Anna Wintour for the love and support on
this historic moment in the caption
um I mean you know it's it's it's
something I've wanted for for my entire
life but we'll leave with this gem 21
Savages spoof of Vogues what's in my bag
we got Charlotte's Web
it's a real good read I love this book I
read it all the time you know got a bag
inside my bag cause you know
could never have too much bag got Janet
Jackson Anytime Anyplace you know I
can't play it because none of the cars I
drive got CD players but you know I just
keep it for like memorabilia yeah
that's what's in my bag the guys have
yet to address their creative promo plan
but something tells me once the album
drops Friday we may be in for some more
phony fun it's top highest tier of top
givers
[Music]